I want to talk about something that is
supposedly really important to Donald
Trump supporters and to Donald Trump and
to constitutional conservatives it's
this thing called the Constitution in
the back story on this started last week
the idea that Donald Trump's constant
conflicts of interests are not only
becoming more obvious and more apparent
and more numerous but that Trump may
actually be violating the Constitution
if he were to be sworn in on january
twentieth without doing away with these
conflicts of interest that are inherent
to what the guy has been doing for the
last many many decades and this is not
david packmans opinion this is not the
opinion of just crazy liberals or
whoever you want to attribute it to top
ethics lawyers for both george w bush
and for barack obama are very directly
saying if Donald Trump doesn't sell his
companies and put the money in a blind
trust the Electoral College should not
make Donald Trump President of the
United States in January this is Richard
painter the chief ethic ethics counsel
for Republican president george w bush
this is also Norman Eisen the chief
ethics counsel for President Barack
Obama they say if Trump doesn't make
these changes the Electoral College
should reject him and this all relates
to I mentioned this last week I'm
mentioning it again I sort of have a
feeling I'm going to mention it many
times this relates to something called
the Constitution specifically article 1
section 9 which says quote no person
holding an office of profit or trust
shall accept of any present or a
monument whatsoever whatever form any
foreign power without the consent of the
representatives of the people that's not
some liberal website that's the
constitution article 1 section 9 that's
super clear Donald Trump's businesses
are receiving such payments here's an
example okay Donald Trump's DC hotel is
seeking a monument to trump according to
attorney Eisen getting foreign
governments to use the hotel Trump
having this meeting with a hundred
are in diplomats and dignitaries and
leaders and politicians at the new DC
hotel showing it off showing off the
sweets that they could stay in when
maybe they come for state business or to
visit Donald Trump in Washington DC and
diplomats who were interviewed
afterwards actually said oh yeah if we
come to DC we will stay at Trump's hotel
to try to ingratiate ourselves with him
why would we want to stay at the
president's hotel competition that might
upset him will stay in the place that
will make him happy now there's option 1
which is Trump sells these assets and
put them puts them in a blind trust
giving a control of these businesses to
his kids is neither blind nor a trust
I've said it many times Trump is
clueless about this but there is another
option which is that these conservatives
that claim to care about the
Constitution they can actually say
because remember article 1 section 9 has
this a line at the end which says that
the president can't do this without the
consent of the representatives the
Republican House could say we consent to
Donald Trump receiving these presents
and emoluments which I hope that they
don't do I think that as corrupt as our
elected officials are I don't think that
they would do that but that's another
option that would make this all okay a
painter attorney painter told CNN he's
been trying to warn Trump's transition
team about the legal consequences of
what's going on including emailing Trump
adviser and former campaign manager
Kellyanne Conway says that he is being
ignored if Trump is sworn in with the
status quo maintained in terms of his
business interests etc this becomes the
official kleptocracy of the United
States this is a really really a long
shot because we've got hyper partisan
Republicans as Trump's electors even if
they hate Trump they're most likely
going to hate Hillary as much or more
and it's very unlikely that they are
going to do what they need to do but
there's actually a case to be made that
the electors should
elect Hillary Clinton not by ignoring
the point of the electoral college but
by adhering to it Alexander Hamilton uh
was one of the framers who said electors
should apply in his own words right
quote a judicious combination of all the
reasons and inducements which were
proper to govern their choice this means
the electors have the wisdom to either
overrule the people or not they can be
guided by democratic values the reason
that the UH electors would be well
within their rights to say you know
Trump won the electoral vote but we will
vote for Hillary Clinton is that they're
not just cogs in the wheel that they're
considered to be cogs in the wheel by
many people oh the electors are just
there to push a lever to cast a vote to
raise their hand for whoever won the
electoral vote that is not really the
original intent of the electors they are
there to protect the country from an
incompetent candidate this situation if
ever there was a situation where the
electors should uh actually do what they
were intended to do uh this is that
situation bottom line it's up to
Congress to make sure that Donald Trump
operates ethically it's a Republican
House and Senate good luck very unlikely
that that will happen but the electors
are there as a possible safeguard here
which as Alexander Hamilton said someone
that constitutional conservatives like
to quote very often the electors can
actually decide to do what they see is
the right thing here I don't believe
that it's going to happen this is a big
big discussion on our reddit discussion
forum and I would invite you to join the
discussion there go to david pakman.com
slash reddit that's our EDD IT you can
talk about this or any other stories
that you want to on our reddit
discussion forum we'll be back after
this today's episode of the david pakman
show is made possible in part by soothe
soothe is making it easier to find time
to relax no matter where you are you
could be at home you could be at work
you could be traveling you can be here
in the david pakman show studio
you go on the SU the website or app and
you request a massage from a
professional massage therapist in your
location in as little as one hour now I
often get very awkward with the entire
professional massage thing I've only had
two professional massages so I thought
you know what soothe is allowing me to
try this out and to see what it's like I
gave my girlfriend a nice little little
gift but uh and and she really
appreciated it and I was able to be
there and observe how the entire thing
happens and it's fantastic not only
number one was the massage therapist
great she showed up and you can choose a
gender if that's important to you in
terms of a massage therapist she came in
with the table she came in with
everything she needed set up right in
the middle of our living room gave the
massage it wasn't awkward and I kind of
regretted actually giving giving the
gift to to my girlfriend I kinda wanted
it myself but here's the best part and
you know how I feel about the whole
tipping thing one of the most awkward
moments for me is after the the massage
is over how much do you tip you don't
have to tip with soothe it's all
included it is just one price and you
can book the massage in under 10 seconds
on the mobile app or website and if you
use my code Pakman at checkout PA que ma
n you get thirty dollars towards your
first massage check it out tell me what
you think